ces archéologues sont à la recherche du
moindre indice pour raconter la vie de
l'infirmerie mollahs style de l'abbaye
de cluny il a fallu remonter au xième
siècle pour découvrir ce bâtiment décrue
à travers des textes liturgiques tout et
liturgique dans un masters dit ce que
doivent faire les moines qui sont
malades ils doivent aussi aller dans tel
chapais la chapelle sainte marie pour
suivre les offices
comment ça se passe comment et porter la
communion par exemple à ces moines qui
sont malades il y a aussi ce plan
anonyme bâton de 1700 qui a mis les
archéologues sur la piste ces détectives
de l'histoire ont déblayé gratter pour
mettre au jour ses murs et le moindre
indice est important on aura toutes les
informations sur le réseau
hydrographique qui est important aussi
pour savoir comment on récupère les eaux
si on a un système de récupération des
eaux pour aller notamment aux latrines
shop découverte apporte son lot de
réponses grâce à ces fouilles les
chercheurs espèrent pouvoir connaître
l'évolution de la firme e ri du moyen
âge à l'époque contemporaine son
orientation par rapport à l'abbaye ou à
la chapelle sainte marie il découvre
aussi le quotidien des moines malade on
trouve des éléments de forme d'onde et
isolde animaux les moins de malades ils
peuvent manger de la viande ce qui est
pas le cas des moines qui sont pas ma
cabine dans l'habit n'ont pas de rendre
un avion les fouilles de l'infirmerie
monastique sont programmés sur trois ans
depuis les années 30 différentes
campagnes ont été réalisés sur le site
la mise au jour dans d'anciens bâtiments
permet de récolter des informations
essentielles pour connaître la vie de
l'abbaye au cours des siècles